okay so why don't we get started
these i will show you some of the
small paint contest assignments from
previous years
is this is this visible is this
i think i should pull some of the
curtains maybe right
maybe a bit just thanks
how about that
so you can see that even with the small
paint program you can you can make
incredible incredible scenes
so this is the thanks so this is the
state of the art lecture basically what
we are interested in this and the next
lecture
is starting from the very first
algorithm that was ever created to solve
the rendering equation
a classical path tracer up to the
most sophisticated works some of them
which came out less than a week ago
and i won't go into deep mathematical
details for most of these techniques
what i would like you to know
is the basic idea and the intuition
behind the method
and why we are doing the things we do so
deep mathematical details will also be
there
in the form of links where you can
look behind the curtain and you will see
what is
exactly going on in there
now before we start with the
state-of-the-art part
there's a few things that we need to
discuss one
this person so we have talked about
indices of refraction
the index of refraction for different
materials
what was it it was a number
so in every code in every program in
every
theory we use numbers well in reality
indices of refractions are not numbers
they are
in fact functions
what does it mean they could be
functions that depend on the wavelength
of incoming light and what it exactly
means is that
there are materials that refract
incoming light of different colors two
different directions
and that's quite profound because
you will see the beautiful effects of
the dispersion in a second and there are
also some
supplementary videos that you should
take a look at home
this is a good example of it this is a
prism so you can see
that the incoming light is white and the
prism
does break down to this
white incoming light to all possible
colors there are
another good example of this is rainbows
so whenever you are
on a family trip and they are asking
what you're looking at and if you
accidentally don't say rainbow you you
will maybe say
this persian and they will put you in an
asylum instead
so but don't worry you are correct
scientifically and that's all that
matters
you can also see and maybe not so
beneficial and not so beautiful effect
of this person
it is called chromatic aberration this
means that
we have a camera lens that is
possibly not the highest quality and it
can
introduce artifacts like this because
different colors of light
are reflected into different directions
and you don't get the sharp image that
you would be looking for
now this is a dispersion
rendered inside lux render so you can
see that with physically based rendering
you can actually capture this effect
and you can also render diamonds so
if you have a fiance and you would like
to buy
a ring but you're broke because you're a
university student
then you can just render one and you can
also render one with this person
well see if you have a nerd girlfriend
because if so then maybe she will be
happy about it
most people aren't and i speak from
experience
and you can also see this really
beautiful effect
in the old old pink floyd album
cover called the dark side of the moon
there are also some videos about this in
the internet
rendered with lux render take a look now
the first question is is the index of
refraction of glass
constant well let's look it that
obviously we may have glasses that are
made and manufactured in different ways
there are most of them are not
completely clear they are some kind of
some kind of a mixture
so there are different kinds of glass
but let's just pick one
randomly from a database that gives you
indices of refraction
and you can see that it is actually not
flat
it is not a constant there there's
something
happening in the function so this means
that
there are glass types that have
dispersion effects
and even only slightly because you can
see
that behind between the minimum and the
maximum there's not such a large
difference but there is something
so you could say that at least this kind
of glass
introduces some degree of dispersion so
let's take a look
what do you think about this image does
this
caustic have any kind of dispersion
effect or does it not
what do you think
is it a bit more colorful around the
edges or is it completely white
looks exactly it looks a bit red
okay could be could be
give give me one more opinion okay what
do you think
um yeah it's a little bit rough
i don't know like a rainbow or something
it might be a rainbow but it may be
significantly
smaller so maybe you would have to zoom
in really close to see the rainbow
so this is up for debate we could see
that the ior
seems to be non-constant and therefore
there should be a dispersion effect
some artists claim that they can spot
the difference between a physically
based renderer
even for materials like that and simple
rgb rendering
where you cannot render these dispersion
effects correctly
this is up for debit whether you can see
it but science says that yes
there is even if there is a slight
difference there is a difference
if you would like to more know more
about this person
there is this wonderful series called
cosmos a space time of dc
have any of you heard of this before
raise your hand okay a few of you so
this is
this is this is hosted by the
magnificent
neil degrasse tyson yeah neil degrasse
tyson
and you should absolutely watch it so
everyone who who hasn't watched it yet
i'd like to hear your excuse or at least
i like to hear that you will go home and
watch it
so this this episode is about that this
person mostly
and you will know all about this person
if you're watching
okay now we have another question
because we have written
an rgb renderer so we
if if you look up the source code of
small paint
everywhere you just see rgb rgb rgb how
do we write
a correct physically based renderer
and even before that how do we even
represent
light in the visible spectrum
now a good answer to this is to
introduce a function
that describes how much light is carried
at different wavelengths now this would
be
a continuous function that we could call
spectral power distribution
and you can see that at these
lower wavelengths there is not too much
light carried and on the higher
wavelengths there is more
so you can put this representation into
your render
and what you would do is that you would
just a naive solution you would pick a
randomly chosen
wavelength and you would trace array
into the scene
using this wavelength and
if you do this you can actually
do another kind of monte carlo
integration
because you would also add one more
dimension of integration and this one
more dimension would be over wavelengths
because you would also be stochastically
taking random samples of the rendering
equation
for a given wavelength in a given color
and then you would need to sum it up
somehow to get a sensible solution there
is more about this
in pbrt chapter 5.